- Oh!
Hiyah!
- Whoa!
(laughter)
- First, there was contouring.
- Then, there was clown contouring.
- Then, there was candy skull contouring.
- And, now there's tape contouring.
- We're gonna figure out
what that's all about.
- It's Ladylike and today,
we're trying tape contouring.
- I don't really know
anything about contouring.
- Contouring's kind of like a bed of lies.
- I think it looks really
good if you can do it right.
- I've only tried a
powder contouring thing
and I think I get too shy about it,
because I put it, then I'm like,
"Oh, that's too drastic," and so then
I just blend it all away.
- I watched the Instagram that Huda Beauty
put up about tape contouring.
- What? How?
I would like step-by-step instructions.
I'll just have to keep
watching this over and over.
- I'm confused exactly what the tape does,
I guess it just makes it so you have
the right amount of makeup
in the right places?
- You apply tape here, here, here, here,
here, here, here (laughs)
and then you just hope for the best.
- So, I didn't realize that we were
just actually using Scotch Tape.
Oh shit.
Can you go like this?
- This is the most
precision I've ever used
when taping someone's face.
Usually, it's just like (blows raspberry).
- Do you tape faces often?
- No, no.
- What?
- Stop, don't make me laugh.
Don't make me laugh.
- [Voiceover] Oh, there's so much tape.
What even comes next?
- Contouring can be fun.
- I'm having fun.
- I kinda feel like this is already
off to a great start.
- Oh wait, oh, oh.
- What's happening?
- I glued 'em together on accident.
- Ohh, I can see how this would work.
- Am I gonna look like Kim?
- I'm trying, okay?
(scoffs)
- We're just gonna go with it.
Looks a little bit like you
just fell into some mud.
- No.
- I think I did the nose very poorly.
- I don't wanna get emotionally attached
'cause it's sorta like, if it looks bad,
I will get really sad.
(laughter)
But it's too late, my
heart's already in it.
- I'm so terrified right now.
- Why?
- I feel like, it's like brown,
pale, brown, pale.
- Okay.
- Am I ready to go out?
- Now, you're ready.
- No.
- Wow, actually this is kinda cool.
It's like super defined lines.
- Oh.
(laughter)
- I'm sorry.
- Look at all those tiny little hairs.
- Just a couple.
- Okay, I'm gonna use the beauty blender.
- And now, I think we just
hit your face for a while.
- Alright.
- Oh, and it does nothing.
- You feel good?
- Yeah, I feel good about this.
- Am I hitting your face too hard?
- Nah, it's good.
Hit it harder.
- Are we all supposed to know how to use
a beauty blender from birth?
- Yeah.
- Jesus.
- Who am I, Huda?
- You just have a really tan nose.
- You're cupping my head (laughs).
(imitating crying)
- Do you feel contoured?
- Totally.
I've never felt more contoured
in my entire life
which is actually true
'cause I've never contoured.
So, this is actually the most
contoured I've ever been.
- You look a little dead up here.
- You really do hold it
like an artist palette.
- I don't know, I'm like
very invested in your face.
- Thank you.
- Is that what you do?
- Did you just spit on it?
(laughter)
- On your face.
- Do you feel set?
- Oh, I feel set.
- This looks like I did some makeup on you
and you have more makeup
on than when you arrived.
- This is what you look like?
- Ooh.
I don't wanna say I'm
surprised because it's not
that I didn't think you
would do a good job,
I feel like I've never seen this much
makeup on my face.
- Oh.
- What?
- Why, it's not bad at all.
- Do you think it's good?
- Wait, wait, wait.
- Yeah, you kinda have to like see,
- I think I just look tan.
- I think I got too focused on the tape
instead of like actually
focusing on your face.
- I think I look nice.
Shantal did a great job.
- I don't know that you
look that much different,
but at least, I didn't make you look worse
which I think is an accomplishment.
- Went from a nine and a half to a ten.
- Oh, hello, face.
You definitely did a good job.
I think that you blended a
little bit better than I did.
I think that my blending
left something to be desired.
I say you have a future in contouring.
- It's like weird how
emotional this is for me.
Oh my God.
- The tape, I don't
think is helpful at all.
I think it's just an extra stressor.
- The tape helps me
because if there hadn't been tape,
I would not have known
where to put anything.
- And, it like ripped my face.
I think we did a good job
for our skill set.
- I killed it.
- I would not do this on a daily basis.
- I don't have time.
- Look at the amount
of tape that we wasted.
- Oh my God.
- And, this is just a small handful
of the tape that's over here.
It is a little bit a
waste of tape and makeup.
Just a little.
- Lady tested.
- Lady meh.
- [Voiceover] If people
ask me to do this to them
on a daily basis, I'll do it to them.
I'll tape contour anybody's fucking face.